elle est la rivale surprise d'alexandre
loukachenko à la présidentielle bélarus
êtes la nature and of sky à représente
un espoir de changement
son mari blogueurs et opposant
gouvernement actuel est arrêté fin mai
elle réclame alors sa libération et
décide de se présenter à la présidence
professeur d'anglais de formation elle a
réussi à faire émerger une opposition
bélarus pour incarner une opposition
structurée unis devait être la nature
and of sky à cet allié avec deux autres
femmes véronique accepte kahlo la
compagne d'un opposant en exil et maria
kolesnikova la directrice de campagne de
victor babarit qu un ancien banquier
emprisonné alors qu'il souhaitait se
présenter et il se trouve que je suis
dans cette position est que les gens ont
placée en moi tous leurs espoirs
tous leurs désirs de changement il se
trouve que je suis la personnification
de ses espoirs pour la première fois
depuis 2001 les observateurs de
l'organisation pour la sécurité et la
coopération en europe
l'eau et ce ne seront pas présents faute
d'avoir été invité à temps le nombre
d'observateurs nationaux et lui réduit
officiellement pour cause d'épidémie de
coronavirus une situation qui fait
craindre des fraudes selon s'être la
natir and of sky à nous ne pourrons pas
empêcher les fraudes
nous avons vu au cours des deux derniers
jours à quel point cette élection était
font tellement falsifiés il n'y a aucun
espoir qu'ils compteront les bulletins
honnêtement
soyons réalistes alexandre lukashenko à
redoubler d'efforts pour enrayer
l'ascension de svetlana tirs à 9 ce
qu'aia dénonçant un complot jouissant de
la complicité du kremlin pour le faire
chuter ce vendredi vladimir poutine a
assuré son homologue biélorusse qu'il ne
cherchait pas à le déstabiliser avant la
présidentielle
une volonté réaffirmée par la porte
parole de la diplomatie russe
[Musique]
d'une part je ne peux pas évaluer la
transparence des élections avant qu'elle
n'ait eu lieu
d'autre part il y a un groupe
d'observateurs venant de différents pays
qui ont pour seule mission d'évaluer
l'ensemble du processus électoral
enfin depuis des années la fédération de
russie avance au sein de l'oaci eux et
d'autres structures mondiales l'idée
qu'il serait bon d'élaborer notamment
dans le cadre de l'eau a eu un ensemble
de règles qui donnerait un cadre pour
estimer la façon dont des élections
doivent se dérouler du point de vue de
leur transparence à 14 d'avoir les
peuples est stable il a donc acquis
depuis 26 ans ce pays d'europe de l'est
n'a connu que la présidence d'alexandre
loukachenko
face aux allégations sur de possibles
fraudes la france l'allemagne la pologne
ont appelé le président sortant à
garantir un scrutin libre et équitable